lange bevor die europäische union der
sichere verbund von 28 staaten war
blickte vor 50 jahren der ganze
kontinent auf die tschechoslowakei
der burgenländische landtagsabgeordnete
josef bosch welcher sich im spätsommer
1968 in pressburg aufgehalten hatte kam
bei berg zu fuß über die österreichische
grenze und hat folgendes zu berichten
um elf uhr nachts wollten wird die
brücke über die donau passieren und wir
konnten das nicht in der erste panzer
kann sind gegen diese fahrzeugkolonne
sie war circa vier stunden lang und ich
schätze dass es 320 die in der facebook
eingefahren sind für uns war es vor
allen dingen interessant wie sich die
bevölkerung verhalten hat und 12 uhr
nachts waren schon die leute auf der
straße er lernt der panzer natürlich hat
sie aus den betten geholt und um halb
vier uhr früh war eigentlich schon die
erste der erste größere wirbel es am
jugendliche haben bereits die banzer sie
versuchten die bands aufzuhalten
frauen sind ganz vorne stand und wollten
mit händen die rollenden bahn zu stoppen
an der jugendliche wieder rollten
benzinfässer gegen stehen die panzer
aber es war bestimmt ein dramatischer
eine dramatische nach dem preis bürger
sind auch zu dem zeitpunkt gefallen und
sonst hat sich das wieder bis zu früh
etwas beruhigt im frühjahr 1968 kam es
in der tschechoslowakei zu einer
politischen reformbewegung das
herrschende politische kommunistische
system sollte durch reformen abgeändert
werden und mit einem menschlichen
antlitz versehen werden
der parteichef der tschechoslowakei
alexander dubcek leitete diese
reformbewegungen ein und wollte einen
kommunismus mit menschlichen antlitz
schaffen das was diese reformbewegungen
alles umfassend ist dann in weiterer
folge als der sogenannte prager frühling
bekannt geworden
über diese entwicklung in der
tschechoslowakei zeigte sich vor allem
die sowjetunion extrem beunruhigt
befürchtete sieht auch dass es zu einem
übergreifen auf andere staaten des
kommunistischen systems kommen könnte
man versucht über politischen druck
alexander dubcek zur rücknahme dieser
reformen zu bewegen jedoch erfolgten
diese nur sehr zögerlich so dass man
sich letztendlich zu einer militärischen
intervention entschied nach der
prinzipiellen genehmigung der
militärischen intervention begannen sich
in der nacht vom 20
auf den 21 august die truppen des
warschauer pakts in bewegung zu setzen
die politischen vorgänge in der slowakei
wurden natürlich auch in wien mit großer
besorgnis wahrgenommen
insbesondere das militär rechnete dass
es zu einer möglichen militärischen
interventionen der tschechoslowakei
kommen konnte und plante unter dem namen
urgestein entsprechende militärische
grenzschutz maßnahmen in den
morgenstunden des 21
august 1968 wurde das österreichische
bundesheer alarmiert und die planungen
für urgestein ausgelöst aufgrund
politischer vorgaben war es dann
bundesheer jedoch nicht gestattet
unmittelbar an die staatsgrenze heran zu
gehen sondern in einer distanz von 30
kilometer zu verbleiben
letztendlich entschied man sich
lediglich die garnisonen nördlich der
donau zu verstärken
im gegensatz zum krisenjahr 1956
bedeutet der einsatz des bundesheeres im
jahr 1968 einen großen image verlust für
das österreichische bundesheer vor allem
die bevölkerung an der staatsgrenze
fühlte sich von den streitkräften
österreichs im stich gelassen und auch
der extra dafür aufgestellte grenzschutz
war nicht einberufen worden
die weiße urgestein sollte folgendes
bewirken
alle mit dem bundesminister für
landesverteidigung verfügten massnahmen
sind unverzüglich durchzuführen
abmarsch der bereitgestellten verbände
sofort nach erreichen der mars
bereitschaft auf weißen gruppen kommando
1 und 3 es kommt darauf an rasch eine
grenze überwachung sicherzustellen um
einen übertreten von flüchtlingen zu
kontrollieren und diese in sammellager
aufzunehmen kommando der
luftstreitkräfte führt mit saab einsatz
führte aufklärungsflüge über eigenen
staatsgebiet nur die piloten sind streng
anzuweisen grenzverletzungen zu
vermeiden tatsächlich wurde urgestein
nach dem politischen willen des
verteidigungsministers dr georg prada
und der bundesregierung nicht umgesetzt
sondern am 21 august 1968 lediglich die
verstärkung der nördlichen garnison
angeordnet
[Musik]
die besetzung der tschechoslowakei
dauert nun schon mehrere tage
wie erlebt die zivilbevölkerung diese
russische okkupation von wo kommen sie
von roger und haben sie interessant
unterwegs naja ich bin hätten der früh
aufgewacht und der familie wohnt in
einem mit der wohnung auf einmal heran
wie er wird immer was ist los mit konnte
frau mit der hose bei der musik strafe
noch ganze warum ist uns eine maschine
noch nicht was los ist sagt er hat den
ganzen kaserne besser gesehen mit der
band sein examen in die kasernen söldner
in die kasernen nicht ausnahmen tun
haben muss erzählt und haben die
kanonenrohre errichtung des ehrenamtes
und die tschechische soldaten wir uns
gehalten
der hatte es in einer warmen zustand des
an drinnen in der kasse samt bei der
polizei und bei den kitas nette und
schoss sein etwas los ist kaufen die
leute lebensmittel zusammengestellt 1
steht so viel weiter überhaupt nix
amoktat wir jetzt an lebensmitteln und
benzin die grenzkontrolle selbst
eingangskontrolle ist einwandfrei
verlaufen als atome keine
schwierigkeiten kommt überhaupt nichts
das ist in so den gesprächen mit der
losen festgestellt die meisten so
scheint es mir wenn ich sie als aus der
nähe betrachtet sehr junge burschen
nicht das ist auch 17 18 jahren und es
scheint sehr viele bauern die jungs
einfach her zu sein
am 7 den gleichen eindruck ja und die
leute sagen dass sie sogar lesen können
nicht sie nicht lesen können dass ich
glaube dass man soll da ein bisschen man
soll da ein bisschen vorsichtig sein 38
glauben sie nicht dass unsere
unterbrechungen einfach einen taster
theater sind aber wir wollen keine
vorsicht außer acht lassen sollte
niemand profitieren und wurde vor allen
dingen unsere kamera gehalten
es sollte versuchen mit einigen deutsch
sprechen wir sind mit 16 panzer gefahren
einer war gerade in der in der
werkstätte kommt weiß ich nicht mehr
und er ist uns aber in den einsatzraum
in den verfügungsrahmen nach geführt
worden mit dem tieflader und wir sind in
den verfügungsrahmen einstieg in gerthe
wald gefahren
wir sind mit mit dem patrons kommando
und der zweiten kompanie
panzergrenadierbataillon 9 sich damals
in weitere gewesen ist und auch in den
raum plötzlich durch kommando und wir
sind im geld hinein gefahren und
ungemütlich niedergelassen
in bad radkersburg angekommen wurden wir
umfassend informiert über die
vorkommnisse in der tschechoslowakei und
über die möglichkeit dass es auch im
steirischen grenzraum zu aktionen im
zusammenhang mit einem möglichen
einmarsch in oder gegen jugoslawien
kommen könnte dazu wurde befohlen dass
unsere kaserne auch die kasernenstraße
in ferien oder in fellbach zu runter und
verteidigung einzurichten sei das haben
wir getan und haben aus der kaserne eine
kleine festung gemacht dieser zustand
dauerte bis ungefähr 10 september 15
september und danach hatten wir süd
bereitschaft jeden mittwoch auf
donnerstag und jeden samstag sonntag ab
oktober wechseln wir verbände uns
gegenseitig ab einmal der
schwesterpartei wir aber wir sind noch
ungefähr
sechs bis sieben mal über das wochenende
in bereitschaft gesessen während dieser
gesamten zeit war immer scharfe munition
auf den lkw s verfügbar
die vorschläge wurden nicht geöffnet
dass es heute keine munition an die
männer ausgegeben
aber es war immer wir waren immer bereit
für einen möglichen einsatz keine
sondern ein wörtlich der donau wurden
durch das panzerbataillon 10 aus spaß an
das waren 2 panzer kompanien m60 1 war
damals der modernste banzer die eine
komponente nicht alle im land marsch
gefahren nicht mit da ist und wann wir
das heute macht haben und sie stehen
hast du dann erst in der nacht gekommen
die hände sind die kaserne angefahren
und die zweitens durch die stadt fuhren
damals hat man keine umfahrung gegeben
durch die stadt horn in der nacht
durchgefahren und nach dem wahltag war
haben manche fenster offen von den
leuten und auch meine spätere frau die
deutsche gewohnt die leute sind in angst
und schrecken
durch diese intensiven banzer geräusche
den leuten angst und schrecken bekommen
weil sie glaubten nach deutschland rufen
man kann sie zur seite gar nicht mehr
vorstellen
wir befinden uns im ehemaligen dorf
wurmbach dass sich hier seit dem
zwölften jahrhunderts befand und 19 39
im zuge der einrichtung des
truppenübungsplatzes dollars heim heute
allen steckt aufgelassen wurde das dorf
wurde allerdings nach 1945 wieder
besiedelt bis in den 1960 er jahre
hinein sodass es dass eines der wenigen
der für hier auf dem truppenübungsplatz
in achum 1968 noch weitestgehend
bestanden hat heute existiert von dem
dorf nur noch die dorfkapelle gibt
gepflegt wird alle anderen daten sind
teilweise abgetragen worden teilweise
einfach über die jahrzehnte hinweg
verfallen
es gibt die so genannte leider scan
technik wo von flugzeugen aus mit einem
laserscanner die oberfläche abgetastet
wird und mit einem relativ komplizierten
mathematischen verfahren der wald und
die vegetation weg gerechnet werden kann
übrig bleibt eine relais hohe auflösung
des der oberfläche mit der es auch
möglich ist die grundrisse der fundament
mauern die heute im wald versteckt sind
erkennen zu können und auf dieser basis
ist möglich den bauzustand zumindest des
frühen zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
rekonstruieren zu können
wir befinden uns am westrand ganz an
western das struktur- prozess- allen
steckt im bereich der ehemaligen
ortschaft dass dort drüben ist das
berühmte stift zwettl auch hier in hier
ist ein privat gestanden ja mit drei
häusern und hier in diesem bereich und
im waldstück davor war das panzerplatte
und zehn untergebracht hier die panzer
garantiert kompanie drüben war die
banzer kompanie mit dem 60 die
bewachsene zwischen abgerissen es ist
jetzt ein parkplatz für übenden truppen
es ist auch eine große bank sehr
gespannt und daneben und das ist hier
diese kapelle dieses kapelle ist für
renoviert worden
viele viele kapellen
struck los was wurden wieder so weit
dass sie auch zur not benutzt werden
kann
auch hier finden von zeit zu zeit
heilige messe statt das war die rote
linie
ja das war hier der torlinie hier soll
ich den orden ist dann über das dürfte
nicht überschritten werden und hier war
das anfangs september 1968 wurden die
anfänglich 21 sowjetischen divisionen
auf 8 und schließlich auf fünf reduziert
und in die zentrale gruppe der truppen
zusammengefasst infolgedessen wurde das
erste panzer bataillon nach salzburg
siezenheim zurückverlegt am 14 september
1968 machte sich die band sein flieger
abwehr batterie 3 ebenfalls auf den
rückmarsch von allen steigt nach krems
und die garnison mautern die mobile
radarstellung der ersten flieger melde
radar kompanie verblieb bis zum 25
september bei hellmonsödt und kehrte
schließlich nach salzburg zurück in den
september war somit der friedens mäßige
normalzustand wieder hergestellt
die krise und die tschechoslowakei war
damit im umfeld der republik österreich
beendet für nachfolgende generationen
stellt sich jedoch die frage ob eine
derartige situation wie 1968 sich in
einem staatenbund wie der europäischen
union wiederholen könnte niemand kann
heute sagen was morgen sein wird
das lehrt uns die geschichte niemand hat
den zusammenbruch des kommunismus real
vorgesehen
niemand den arabischen frühling so
wurden auch viele andere einsätze die
von heute auf morgen entstanden nicht
vorgesehen und man kann daher auch heute
als 20 18 nicht sagen was morgen konkret
sein wird kann ich mir nicht vorstellen
wir haben ganz andere bedrohungen
heutzutage migration
cyber bedrohungen und so weiter aber
momentan kann ich mir das in europa
nicht vorstellen